un mois et demi après son élection
l'ultraconservateur ici appris ce matin
à ses fonctions de nouveau chef de
l'état on héran ancien chef de
l'autorité judiciaire il devra
poursuivre le travail de son
prédécesseur france à leurs familles une
tâche qui s'annonce compliquée arrivera
ici devra faire face à trois défis de
taille pour relever un pays qui souffre
sur les plans économique diplomatique et
sanitaires yamina benguigui
les dossiers s'accumulent sur la table
des baïnes raïssi désormais
officiellement président dès son
élection le nouveau chef d'état s'est
dit prêt à poursuivre le travail de son
prédécesseur hassan rohani nous allons
certainement utiliser les expériences du
gouvernement actuel avec la coopération
de monsieur roy ni et de tous les
manques du gouvernement j'utiliserai
certainement les opinions points de vue
expériences et rapport des ministres et
fonctionnaires estimé pendant cette
période d'un mois et demi
l'homme âgé de 60 ans doit traiter
plusieurs dossiers brûlants
parmi eux l'épineuse question du
nucléaire
des pourparlers avec certaines grandes
puissances avaient repris dès l'entrée
de joe biden à la maison blanche met
enfin la décision de son prédécesseur
donald trump d'abandonner l'accord de
vienne
mais washington et téhéran peine à
rétablir un lien de confiance
le fait est que c'est l'iran qui est des
décisions à prendre des décisions
fondamentales à prendre pour savoir s'il
veut lui aussi revenir au respect de
l'accord et aucun niveau de diversion ne
peut changer ce fait fondamental
la balle reste dans le camp de l'iran et
nous verrons s'ils sont prêts à prendre
les décisions nécessaires
ni au respect de l'accord nous sommes
attachés à la diplomatie mais ce
processus ne peut pas se poursuivre
indéfiniment
l'accord actuellement suspendu devrait
être relancé dès la prise de fonction
d'ebrahim raïssi mais les négociations
pourraient toutefois être ralenti par le
dernier incident opposant la république
islamique d'iran à l'état hébreu
israël accuse téhéran d'être à l'origine
de l'attaqué meurtrière d'un navire géré
par un milliardaire israélien dans la
merde oman un contexte qui complique le
rétablissement des relations avec l'iran
mercredi dernier ali khamenei le guide
suprême d'iran mettait en garde les
générations futures devraient se servir
de l'expérience du gouvernement rouani
il est apparu clairement en cours du
mandat de ce gouvernement que faire
confiance à l'occident ne fonctionne pas
la crise économique et sociale dans le
pays est amplifié par la pandémie du
coronavirus elle vient s'ajouter à la
liste des dossiers auxquels le nouveau
président iranien devra faire face en
juillet des manifestations parties de
pénurie d'eau dans la région pétrolifère
du khouzistan ont secoué tout le pays